-Welcome back.
-Thanks, Seth.
-Big news in Zach's world.
-Yes.
-You just got a puppy.
-I got a puppy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I know --
I know from experience,
obviously, the hardest par
about getting a puppy
is potty-training them.
How is it going?
-Well, it's going okay.
I went to the park.
And then,
in addition to potty training,
we were working on getting him
not to pull on the leash.
And so, the way you're suppose
to do that, evidently, is like
if they go in one direction,
you go in the other.
But it took a long time
because he's a puppy,
and 'cause I'm up late,
I've been drinking a lot of,
like, tea and coffee and stuff
-Sure.
-So by the time
I was done at the park,
I really had to pee, myself.
-Mm-hmm.
-And --
But there was only one of those,
like, park murder restrooms.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-...where like, if you go in
there's an 80% chance
someone's gonna make
upsetting eye contact with you
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, I didn't go,
and I was like,
"I can make it home.
No problem."
And I got in the car,
and I was driving,
and I realized that
it was much more urgent
than I had initially realized.
-Uh-huh.
And it sort of felt like -
You know, in, um...
like, action movies,
when there's, like,
the door is closing
and the guy has to roll under?
-Sure, sure.
-It was sort of
a urethral version of that
[ Laughter ]
And I got home, and I was like
"Okay, I can make it."
And I got up
to go into the house,
and I couldn't
find my house keys.
And I started to really panic.
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "I'm about to
urinate in my own pants.
I'm gonna go into my garag
to pee in the garage."
And I live in a condominium,
so there's people.
And then I couldn't get
the garage door open.
And I had the dog in the garage.
And I just realized,
"This has to happen here."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I stood in my parking lot
Seth, and I peed my pants at 35.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Yeah.
You did it, you did it.
-But here's the thing.
Like, the dog looked at me like,
"I thought we weren't
supposed to do this."
[ Laughter ]
And then, I had to go upstairs
and my shoes were wet.
And I was gonna --
I told --
Like, if I saw a neighbor,
I'm gonna tell them
the dog peed on me.
And then, I had to use
the stuff we use
to clean up after the dog
when he pees in the house
to clean up my footprints.
[ Laughter ]
It was really degrading.
I'm sorry
that you had to hear that.
-Yeah. Thank you for sharing
-Yeah.
-Have you --
I know when you have a dog
people will give you their
advice on being dog owners
Have you gotten any good advice?
Have people told you what
it's like to be a dog owner?
-Well, one -- a friend of mine
said to me, she was like -
she said, "Do you know why dog
don't live as long as people?"
And I said, "No."
And she said, "Because
they already know how to love.
And I was, like, "Jesus Christ."
[ Laughter ]
"You have to warn me befor
you say things like that.
Like, I have to continue to live
as an adult.
I just want to go, like, liste
to Judy Garland and cry."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
And the trainer said that, like,
physiologically, when a dog --
when you come home,
the event in a dog's brain
like, the dopamine levels
is like falling in love,
like a human falling in love
but it happens six times a day
-Wow.
-So when you come home,
and you're like,
"Oh, I've had a long day,"
and the dog's like --
and you don't pay attention,
it's like "Romeo and Juliet.
Or no, not even.
Because those guys were in lov
with each other.
Yeah.
-Romeo and, uh, Kathy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Not today, Kathy."
I remember the first time
I yelled at our dog, Frisbee
because she was behaving badly
And I realize, at some point
I have to yell at her,
and I was like, "Frisbee, no!"
And she just looked at me,
and then turned to the sid
and threw up.
-[ Gasps ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It was so traumatic for he
that she was like, "No."
-Oh, my God.
That's so sad.
-So just be careful.
Just, like, ramp up to it.
-I also wish I had that
in my own emotional repertoire
which is when someone hurt
my feelings or criticizes me
I could just barf.
[ Laughter ]
-It would be great.
It would be like,
"Just think twice next time.
[ Laughter ]
"-Zach, we've got some notes -
[ Mock vomits ]
-They're like,
"I saw him pee himself
in the parking lot, and then
he threw up in the meeting."
-He is in control of none
of his bodily functions.
-So this is a remake of a film
a Swedish film
called "Force Majeure."
-Right.
-And it takes place
at a ski resort.
Were you a skier going into it
We see you at the top
of a mountain there.
-Yeah, I was not a skier before.
But now, I am still not a skier.
-Gotcha.
-And the only time
I had ever been skiing befor
was cross-country skiing
as a boy.
And I hated it, with, like
an indescribable intensity
to the extent
that I took my ski pole --
and this is gonna make me soun
like an incontinent psychopath
But I took my ski pole and I
stabbed my brother in his calf
[ Audience groans ]
And he was like,
"What the hell?!"
And I was, like,
"Someone had to pay."
[ Laughter ]
I hated --
I hated it so much
that I hurt him for no reason.
-And you're in Austria?
-Yeah.
-How was -- And I would imagin
you're at a ski resort.
You're at a beautiful mountain
Is that where you
spend your time?
eat your meals?
-Yeah.
It was breathtaking.
But the restaurant was
really weird, because they -
I don't know
if this is true everywhere
but in this particular resort,
they dress in this kind of
like, 19th-century servant garb,
that the waiters --
they look like they just escaped
a cuckoo clock or something.
They've got these sort of,
like, lederhosen.
And there was this one guy
and he had this laugh.
You know, it's a weird thing
when you're in
a different country,
you don't know
if you're committing faux pas.
And he had this thing
where like, okay, like --
You be me and ask, like,
for a bottled water.
-Got it.
Do you have bottled water?
-Oh. Oh-ho-ho!
[ Laughter ]
-He would go like that!
And then, I'd be like,
"Did I do something wrong?
I'd be like,
"You know, whatever."
-Did you do something --
"Did I do something wrong?
-Oh. Oh-ho-ho!
[ Laughter ]
-I ended up eating in my room,
Seth, because I didn't
want to deal
with the social anxiety.
-Well, I'm glad the film
worked out, nonetheless,
and you worked past
both those hurdles
of not being a skier
and dealing with that waiter
-Thank you so much.
It's a real form
of moral heroism.
[ Laughter ]
-Congrats on the dog.
And thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasur
to see you.
-Thank you.
-Zach Woods, everybody.